i think that when you challenge
orthodoxy
um rather than examining
whether the criticism of the orthodoxy
is valid or not
uh you seek to dismiss the other person
with abuse and insults it was the great
uh gandhi wasn't it
who said about the campaign for indian
independence from the british empire
you know first they ignore you
then they laugh at you then they attack
you and then you win
a complete refusal to deal with ideas
and a belief that just by hurling abuse
you can destroy the other side
um and and i mean cameron tried it's
quite funny actually cameron tried it
uh cameron was on with nick ferrari on
rbc
he was asked about nigel farage and ukip
oh he said a bunch of fruitcakes loonies
and closet racists mostly
now that was quite a wounding thing
for a prime minister to say about a
party that i led
but actually it helped us because people
could see how unreasonable
he was being you know everyone said oh
farrow stands for this farage stands for
that
well have you ever ever actually read
what he's actually said
and it was as if people were choosing to
interpret what i'd said
rather than actually reading the words
and and and you know truth of it is that
nation states make their own laws
nation states have their own courts
nation states control their own borders
and choose who they think are fit and
proper people to come and settle in
their country i mean these were all
perfectly reasonable
sensible points of view but were
demonized because they challenged
the establishment and i you know i would
say this
uh to anybody uh that tries to
you know paint out ukip and and and what
it stood for
in in that racist way you know i was the
only party leader
who banned anybody who'd ever been a
member of the british national party
from even becoming a member of uk you
know i drew that line
within my own party and you know
something
in 2006 nick griffin had quite a big
tailwind behind him
you know a lot of dispossessed white
working class who were very unhappy
what was happening in their communities
had started to vote for nick griffin
once i drawn that line that we wouldn't
accept
bnp members and supporters but if you
were
holding your nose and voting vmp as a
protest but didn't agree
with their outright racist policies you
could come and vote for me
and they did i think i did more i mean
here we are
here's the funny thing about my critics
i honestly believe
i did more to stop the rise of the far
right in this country than any other
individual i really mean
you